let's talk about this we got the story
from the guardian let's pull this up
sound of Freedom passed the 100 million
dollar Mark who's really watching the
movie they say the Q Anon adjacent film
co-opted by the right wing has a Pay It
Forward scheme resulting in sold out
shows but empty theaters that is a lie
flat Outlaw their evidence is that they
went to a local theater check out the
weasel language they use here according
to Fandango all but 28 seats had been
sold for the 3pm screening of sound of
Freedom as the lights dimmed however the
guardian counted 45 vacant seats dotted
around the half empty theater full stop
the lights dim twice
when a movie ends the lights go full
brightness
then the lights will dim slightly for
pre like the the movie go whatever it's
called pre-screener where it's like you
know lasers and you hold your phone and
stuff then it dims then the lights shut
off
my question is
are they lying by manipulating so uh
being factual but not truthful in that
when the lights dim and half the theater
was empty are you saying that people
showed up early for the movie and then
when the lights dimmed for the previews
the theater was half empty or you sang
When the Lights actually dimmed for the
start of the film The Theater was empty
check this out he says minutes before
the 6 30 screening Fandango showed that
only two seats were available again
there were more than two vacant spots as
the film began three
wow that was more than two mean well
that's empty more than two definitely
means it's not a cell no one is there it
sounds like what actually happened was
the theater was half full before the
previews even started right the lights
dim and they're like theater is f empty
yeah then before the movie actually
starts there's like six seats that are
available and they're like more than two
more some people didn't shop yeah some
people missed their movie well take a
look at this currently sound of
Freedom's at 124 million was Obama's
chef that's right and uh number three
only behind Barbie and Oppenheimer of
course those are the big movies that
just came out
sound of freedom is beating Mission
Impossible
yes sorry Tom Cruise take that
beating Mission Impossible you know the
flash is considered the biggest one of
the if it may be the biggest box office
bomb in history wow did it just come out
it's odd when you take somebody who
kidnaps women and tortures them and then
you're like you can still be the Flash
they made back like 260 of their 400
million so they were like we can't
cancel this film I'll look I'll take 50
cents on the dollar but I'm taking I'm
not taking zero yeah I really like
Michael Shannon too I feel bad that he's
got to take a hit on that one yeah who
is he in the movie uh I guess he's the
bad guy I don't know who he plays but I
wonder how many of the people involved
with the flash are making money off of
it like when 240 million comes in of
your 400 does the production house eat
it and they're like sorry BlackRock ESG
will pay it forward yeah we'll donate to
some kids in Rwanda or something I also
feel that with superhero movies it's
like it's fine we'll just make it all
back with every other superhero movie we
make this year yeah don't worry about it
I assume it's not like per movie there's
an ultimate you know yeah and even that
it's like yeah we lost a couple hundred
million but we still made back a few
hundred million so it's not like the end
of the world for these studios Okay no I
I mean I think I think it's about
Netflix right now Netflix had a bunch of
um like house related flipping show
shows that are all Netflix originals
like that they're like you're looking at
these these things you're like how much
is the budget per episode here but it's
because ultimately Netflix is trying to
decide which style of show people are
going to watch which they'll renew
they're able to throw up a ton of losses
if they can ultimately decide it's worth
it as a business investment because they
are making money off of other things
yeah did you know there was a movie
called Ruby Gilman teenage Kraken that
came out no time just like looking at
the box office
the blackening I wanted to see what is
it it's like a horror movie but it's uh
it's by the people that did
um get out oh no not get out but yeah I
see I see what you did I don't know I
know no no they did um they did a parody
two of another uh it is like parodies of
Black movies
um but this one is yeah they all go to a
camp or go to a house in the woods so it
is like all black people in a house in
the woods horror movie the the tagline
is we can't all die first exactly yeah
that's awesome yeah so I do want to see
that one actually the big the big news
is
uh we're nearly 20 or 20 days on nearly
about three weeks on sound of Freedom uh
it's on Saturday hit 7.5 million dollars
beating uh I'm sorry on Friday they beat
Mission Impossible by 200k about 140k
they lost Sunday by about 400k but then
uh almost uh 700 000 sound of Freedom
beats Mission Impossible on Sunday the
crazy thing is
sound of Freedom has consistently been
hitting Millions every day Saturday July
15th 10 million dollars Friday 7 million
dollars this is amazing so here's what I
want to say about the guardian
they're trying to make it seem like
suspicious sales the theaters are empty
but they're claiming they saw it and I'm
like there were two seats with people
that weren't even in them if you think
you're gonna go to Hollywood Studios and
say
don't support these movies people are
willing to pay to see it and not
actually even go to the theater
the studio is going to be like hold on
people are giving money in exchange for
nothing they're just like literally
giving their money away
can we make more of these why would a
studio say no to that yeah or a movie
house because it's less upkeep on the
house to have to clean after exactly
yeah people have to be like with their
morality tales and the guy the studio is
like oh I work for the devil yeah is
there a way to do this yes
oh I can't make these at all it's kind
of even our contract I just I love how
their smear is this movie was so
important that people are paying for
tickets but not actually going as if
that's going to like discredit it in any
way it's the most cat it's a capitalist
dream you mean I can bake the cake and
keep it and you're gonna pay me money
anyway just yeah that's amazing and you
know this semi-feminist uh Barbie movie
is not able to say the same thing like
our movie's so culturally important
please buy tickets for other people
people you may not even know like where
is the Barbie go buy tickets for other
people camping it doesn't exist because
that movie obviously doesn't tell a
story that people want to hear or feel a
moral imperative to share with the
people that's what's one of the things
that's so unique about sound of Freedom
you just can't replicate that everywhere
well no and it's a it's very important
for people to see I mean I have a son
right after I saw it he was yelling he
was wearing bright yellow for the next
three days because it's haunting I mean
it really is a terrible story and it's
it's very real I I think it's odd that
it's taken this long for people to kind
of open their eyes in this way to human
trafficking because it's everywhere and
it's been everywhere in plain sight for
a very very long time but at least it's
finally out there and people are getting
to be a little bit more aware of it but
it it it's important and it's important
that these tickets are available for
people because a lot of it is just for
people who can't afford to go to the
movies that's why people are buying them
so you can just see it yeah it matters
and that's not Barbie it's like you've
made 800 Barbies now for everybody where
you have like handicapped wheelchair
Barbie you have spina bifida Barbie you
have all these things but then you make
the movie and it's just hot ass Barbie
he's not joking ladies and gentlemen no
I'm sorry why didn't lizzo play I was
shocked she didn't but like it was like
real though no I I they were like they
would that's why everyone tried claiming
Margot Robbie was unattractive because
the reality was oh I know she's she's
conventional Hollywood attractive she's
like the conventional Hollywood
beautiful actress yes but they have to
say that because then people are gonna
come up oh why wouldn't Barbie it's a
feminist film why didn't they cast lizzo
or a trans woman
yeah that's true that's why I don't even
look at the cover of Sports Illustrated
because I don't know anymore
you know well the reality is their
ideology is it's it's nonsense here's
the funny thing remember the movie Bros
you know that one yeah I know oh Billy
Billy Eichner is a gay comedy one yeah
okay nope it bombed miserably no it was
like one of the worst yeah bombs yeah
and he's he's at this show and he's
walking through the I'll be like
everybody please go see this movie you
have to nobody wanted to pay a dime for
it especially gay men but I mean look
maybe they did want to see it I don't
know I'm just saying he's the ones I
knew were like no but if you're talking
to three percent or like point in one
one percent of the population your
market cap is going to be one percent of
typical box office market cap if you
make a movie that's like called all men
are dumb don't expect men to go see it
if you make a movie about a gay
relationship don't expect straight
people to go see it well they didn't
here's the thing sound of freedom is the
inverse of that people on the right post
liberals people who care about this
issue they want the movie so badly
they're willing to pay extra for other
people to go see it yeah it's like
information like you're actually going
to see to learn some information it is a
doc It's a drama about a real life story
but you're still learning like about
real life things so it's like it's like
a documentary and sadly you're getting
clips of the real life events yeah
literally yeah and that's that's
horrifying but when you see it you
realize how you know how fast it can
happen yep and how you know little
people can do about it because you have
grown men with guns who pull up to kids
playing soccer or whatever on the street
and what are they gonna do they're just
trying to say whatever kids are just
sitting there and then you have and then
who what are the most egregious places
where human trafficking happens they go
right to Los Angeles it's one of the top
three I I also want to point this out
too
in the guardian storages in a theater
located in New York City's Times Square
on Thursday afternoon there seemed to be
evidence of this you mean to tell me
that a Thursday afternoon they sold half
the theater out I don't buy it no no a
Thursday yeah yeah we we always go who
goes to a 3 P.M Thursday showing the if
you even look at the sign of Freedom box
office it's big days are weekends duh
this is why movies get released with
Thursday previews over weekends so
you're saying two weeks out almost three
weeks out on a Thursday they were able
to put Philip half the theater yeah come
on well it looks like they filled up
almost the entire theater by the time
the movie started no no two seats all
but two at least two seasons more than
two that means three do you think there
were tourists on a Tuesday afternoon in
times I mean that's my goodness maybe
but what I find fascinating is the the
fact that they're not acknowledging that
you could go to any movie and be like
one of two people in the theater and
they still consider that movie a success
right this this idea that they're not
feeling they're not selling out every
single show every single time but
they're still making tons of money is it
relevant to them they're manipulating
all of their data to try to make this
look bad it's the same thing with this
like Q Anon slur right like they have
just decided this might be the way to
scare people away from going right to
say like actually that many people
aren't seeing it you're you're confused
because actually not every seat is sold
and we checked this one time like it's
it's ridiculous well it's interesting
because it's the only place in Times
Square that you're not spending money on
human trafficking at that hour
that's man no it's true I'm just saying
it's a creepy place
for a while you do yeah there's really
and then well of course if you eat don't
finish your Red Lobster you can just set
it on a homeless guy's tent because that
seems like a good idea thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time